bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors le venezuela en
colère après un rapport de l'onu sur les
droits de l'homme
que reproche caracas à ce document alors
écoutez j'ai lu le rapport de l'onudc ce
rapport assez long me suis couché à 2
heures du matin pour pouvoir bien le
décortiquer et aller à la source
finalement et pas sur les
interprétations médiatique effectivement
comme l'a dit là dans le petit reportage
les rapporteurs par les enquêteurs de
l'onu ont des motifs raisonnables pour
croire voilà l'article 9 de ce rapport
dit
cette norme est respectée lors que des
lorsque des informations factuelles ont
été recueillies qui satisfont pour un
observateur prudents les objectifs que
l'incident s'est produit tel que décrit
avec un degré raisonnable de certitude
mais c'est un peu léger comme
méthodologie est d'ailleurs l'article
1977 de ce même rapport c'est pas moi
qui invente précise bien que les
conclusions de la mission n'équivalent
pas une condamnation pénale et les
informations présentées ici sont pour la
plupart inférieures à celles qui sont
nécessaires pour obtenir une
condamnation pénale
donc en fait il n'y a aucune preuve
tangible j'aimerais pas du tout être
jugés par des par des gens qui ont cette
méthodologie de d'un 10,2 se pourrait
que dans une certaine mesure
en réalité ce n'est pas sérieux ce
rapport se base sur des témoignages de
personnes condamnés pour tentative de
coup d'état ou sédition sur des articles
de presse de médias farouchement opposé
à nicholas maduro et sur des rapports
des ong financée par les états unis
c'est à dire par le gouvernement
ouvertement hostiles au gouvernement
vénézuélien
ce n'est pas sérieux finalement à ce que
ce rapport à une quelconque valeur
j'aurais dit que j'entends oui eux en
réalité pas des masses à part une valeur
politique et symbolique car cela révèle
surtout un conflit au sein des
institutions de l'onu
la chronologie est importante le 20
septembre 2010
9 l'année dernière le haut commissariat
aux droits de l'homme de l'onu donc
michelle bachelet avait signé un
partenariat avec le venezuela pour
améliorer ce qu'il y à améliorer dans
les droits de l'homme pour pour le pays
en réponse le groupe de lima
c'est-à-dire ce conglomérat de
gouvernements néolibéraux qui s'opposent
au venezuela a fait approuver la
résolution 42,25 par le conseil des
droits de l'homme qui donnait naissance
à la mission qui a rédigé ce rapport
et là encore une fois la chronologie est
intéressante puisque deux jours avant la
parution du fameux rapport
michelle bachelet exprimé sa
satisfaction dans les avancées avec le
gouvernement vénézuélien et notamment le
déclaré que son équipe technique avait
pu visiter des centres de rétention
à la différence de la mission qui je le
répète n'est pas allé au venezuela n'a
pas mis un pied au venezuela
donc en fait la voix de l'onu n'est pas
monolithique et il s'agit surtout par ce
rapport de faire pression sur
l'opposition démocratique qui veut
retourner sur le chemin des urnes et sur
le chemin constitutionnel le 6 décembre
prochain et aussi fait pression sur le
bureau de michele bachelet c'est une
opération que l'éthique rapport qui
intervient à un moment très délicat pour
le venezuela une crise socio économique
qui touche le pays depuis à peu près
sept ans maintenant est ce que vous êtes
optimiste par la suite pour la suite
écoutez vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que
le venezuela et en est en guerre alors
pas une guerre comme on a l'habitude de
cela représenté par les images de l'irak
de 2003 le venezuela subi des offensives
institutionnels des offensives
diplomatiques une offensive économique
avec ce l'infâme blocus qui affame la
population et puis des offensives
militaires je rappelle qu'il ya quand
même eu six coups d'état ou tentatives
de coups d'état pour l'année 2019 et
pour l'année 2020 on en est déjà à trois
opérations militaires contre le
gouvernements légitimement élus face à
cela une partie de l'opposition non
négligeable a décidé de tourner la page
de cette confrontation violente et 2
mesurée dans les urnes c'est-à-dire de
rebattre les cartes du jeu démocratique
est d'isoler la fraction ultraviolente
écoute schiste représenté par les états
unis et monsieur guido et ses seins en
fait qui est en jeu aujourd'hui par
cette opération politico médiatique pour
essayer de faire juger monsieur maduro
par la cour pénale internationale
puisque c'est la recommandation numéro
65 du rapport remis par la mission de
l'onu il ya deux jours romain milus
merci pour votre éclairage vous rappelle
que vous êtes journaliste spécialiste du
venezuela encore merci